hello my name is zach lose and i am nine
years old and today i'm having two chefs
compete to create my dream dish take me
to your leader
yay
hey how's it going oh it's good i'm
hannah by the way
we heard that you know a lot about
aliens i'm sort of like
the alien specimen specialist i know two
types of aliens the one that i know more
about is this alien called a mini mudu
so they have triangular feet instead of
hands like we do they have claws like
crabs and they have four antennae with
two eyes and one mouth zach is just such
a well-spoken kid he's very smart and
he's very passionate about anything he
talks about clearly now that we know
what they look like i'm dying to know
what do these mini moodoos eat so of
course since they are in space they have
to eat things from space so they have
this like giant moon chunk here
they also like chunks of a planet so
let's just say that they eat chunks from
i don't know jupiter and inside there
would be like a hint of the big storm
eye it can be a bit spicy for their
taste oh spicy sometimes kids say they
want spicy but they don't they also have
comets they are extra extra hot so he's
drawing the comet and i'm getting very
excited about the fire that he's drawing
because i think i could have some good
ideas for that for their garnishes they
have like specks of moon dust around
their plate i mean like they really like
their moon dust but they also have some
rings from saturn and books of rings
from neptune so the drawing keeps
getting more detailed i don't really
know how i'm going to fit all this on
one plate or what food is going to make
all these shapes i think i might have an
idea for the rings i don't know if he's
going to like it we won't let you down
zack good luck okay
so my game plan for this dish is two
fluffy purple japanese style pancakes a
little puddle of yogurt with some fruit
in the middle to make it look like that
storm for the moon dust i think i'm
gonna crush some chocolate cookies and
use the bigger pieces as those moon
rocks that he was talking about so for
the rings i have strawberries mango and
peach rings the candy and i might do a
mixture of the three here's my plan i'm
going to make rice crispy moon rock
comet and jupiter i'm going to dip those
in a glaze of greek yogurt and powdered
sugar that i'm going to marble with gel
food coloring and then i'm going to make
rings for saturn and neptune with hand
pulled taffy and then i'm going to melt
jolly ranchers and make little fire
sticks for the comet for the moon dust
i'm gonna get some nerds throw those all
at the bottom of the dish and sprinkle a
little bit on our moon rock
and there you go
all right
so these rings this is where i'm like
risky and maybe not worth the effort i'm
gonna make some taffy from scratch
why oh my gosh
this is my first time on i draw you cook
and like i am just i am so nervous about
it also hannah has two kids i don't have
kids katie has such an advantage because
i have two kids so am i well rested no
are my pants ironed no do i remember
what day it is no i'm a complete shell
of a human all right i think we should
get started because we both have a lot
to do yeah where's my stuff okay i hope
that they make it both huge delicious
and well made the best chef win the
taffy i have to be pretty like accurate
about so i just want to make sure i'm
doing all the right proportions i'm
going to first get my sugar and i'm
going to sift in cornstarch and then i'm
going to add in some corn syrup which i
know is you know pretty intense so this
is a kid's
dream dish so i'm just going big i'm
going big on the sweets see you also
have the advantage of not being a mom
like that am i breaking a rule and i'm
just like sweet sweets while your mom's
gone i'm gonna let this get to 250 if it
goes above that when this candy cools it
is going to crack and it will not be
that great taffy pull that we need um
whoa
this is going to be the hot mess edition
yes i draw you cook hotness
so what i'm assuming makes these
japanese pancakes fluffy is the egg
whites are beaten separately so i beat
the egg whites until they have stiff
peaks that means when you lift up the
beaters
it comes to a point and it stays like
that
that's gonna take a bit this all
happened a lot faster in my head i'm
gonna mix that up with pancake batter
and milk and butter and a little bit of
egg yolk and hopefully it comes together
i'm kind of winging it and then i'm
gonna use these thick ring molds to
hopefully get them to be a little more
vertical and fluffy usually the first
pancake is always bad whenever you're
making pancakes like i throw out the
first pancake so this one's just a test
this is just like a this is for you
i don't know how full i'm supposed to do
this
for the comment fire i'm just gonna melt
some jolly ranchers in the microwave i
didn't know you could microwave yeah
what
you gotta make sure you're in a it's a
good
super safe heat proof bowl okay they
look like those hands that stick and
you're like yeah yeah so he too flames
coming out of his comet so i have
mangoes so i'm gonna slice them very
thin and fan them out to be my comet
flames all right and here we go
pour out the taffy let it cool and then
we have to work the taffy and that means
i'm just going to be pulling it over and
over and over again until it starts
changing colors more white and solid you
know those machines that
pull the taffy
i'm the machine today can i use your
bigger tongs do you have bigger tongs i
don't you do oh take him i wasn't trying
to sabotage you a wink get this under o
m g this is gonna spill i'm gonna throw
up if i can't flip this pancake i have
to start all over i've already waited so
long to have this pancake cook all the
way through because i poured a lot of
batter in this ring
did you flip it no i dropped it
i'm just praying at this point that i
can flip the pancake and have a success
i can't i can't
no no
i need to do less batter
let's get this out of here oh that's
sticky it's gonna be sticky guys just
everyone just has a bear with me i mean
my hands look horrifying then i'm really
sorry that you have to see this just
like if no one can look at me right now
that's what i would like
i've made this before and it is way
stickier than normal i mean it usually
sticks to your hands a little bit but it
is way stickier i think you might have
made like a good
choice of what you did i think i'm
trying to do too many things at once and
i'm a little worried about the taffy not
getting to the right point this is a
workout i can't imagine i have these
cookies because he talked a lot about
moon dust and i feel like moon dust is
probably grayish for like the moon dust
i'm thinking that they're gonna put
white
cheese
like like scraped and cut i feel like i
have everything else nailed down but i'm
just waiting on these pancakes they're
taking a long time
i'm afraid that i'm gonna have another
flop of a flip i feel like i need
something to do while i wait for this
like everyone on cooking shows is like
got my sauce going i'm gonna make a
quick ice cream and i'm just like
watching a pancake a normal pancake is
very standard the bubbles start to pop
on one side and you know it's pretty
much done it's very easy to tell but
with this much batter in it and with the
size of it it's totally different
so if these don't work i'm giving up and
i'm just gonna do some regular pancakes
and you get what you get and you don't
get upset
[Music]
second time's the charm i flipped it i
don't even care what happens at the end
of this competition at this point
because i flipped my dang pancake i did
it
i flipped it
how are you doing
that's not good
i just got too much grease on it i
greased my hands too much and now the
taffy is too moist it's getting stringy
which is not what you want with taffy
okay i'm gonna regroup
myself here rice krispie treats so quick
easy you just throw in butter add all of
our marshmallows let that all melt down
i'm gonna add in my rice krispies i'm
gonna stir that in kind of eyeball it
and just for fun i add a few more
marshmallows at the end so you get
little marshmallow chunks i feel like
with these rice krispies i'm going to
get it back on track to make the marble
glaze i'm going to sift powdered sugar
add some greek yogurt my food coloring
and swirl that together and then i'm
going to dip in my rice krispies i have
all my pieces and now hopefully they all
go together on this plate for the
jupiter that he drew with the storm i'm
just using vanilla greek yogurt and i'm
gonna put a little bit of mango to make
that little orange circle in the middle
as i'm taking the moon rock out of the
glaze i know this is going to work so
i'm feeling like we might be okay
oh
it's so happy
a little more moon rock
and rock down here
boom katie's dish looks like a dish just
for kids and my dish looks like a brunch
option at a hipster restaurant are you
done yeah it's all good we did it we did
it i think we should see what zack
thinks
okay do i have cookies in my teeth
no you're good no cookies
visually i feel good about the dish i
tried really really hard i really went
the extra mile in terms of getting
creative and it all comes down to
whether or not this appeases a
nine-year-old's taste buds the closer
zach gets to eating my dish the more
nervous i'm getting because this is my
first time i am feeling really really
really nervous i think that it looks
really fun and really cool and if i was
a kid
i would get excited to see it but i do
think it's a lot of sugar so we'll see
if this kid can take it
bring on my planetary feasts
this
is not what i expected and i forgot to
mention that i don't really like
blueberries
oh i thought for sure i was safe with
that
dang it
oh the inside's like a purple that's
cool
[Music]
it's light and fluffy so good especially
with the maple syrup you like the
pancake i i feel like i might have a
chance okay so for the strawberries
they taste good
could be a bit more riper though
what i like best would be
the yogurt and the pancake batter thing
and the thing that i like leaves would
be these or the blueberries i'm getting
mixed signals from him that is giving me
flashbacks from last season and i'm just
i'm not feeling very good about this now
bring on my other
planetary feast
wow
this one definitely resembles the
drawing board it feels so good i thought
it looked like the drawing he thought it
looked like the drawing i mean like it's
not moon dust moon just could i'm not
saying that this is actually true they
say that the moon is made out of cheese
apparently moon dust is supposed to
taste like cheese did not know that i
need some help prying this um
from the plate
i just heard a loud thud which i'm just
hoping is not the taffy
but probably is the taffy
let's just pretend that didn't happen
okay wow
so sticky
i think this is like rice krispie treats
or something rice krispies is my second
favorite cereal
these are delicious
i like these
the rice krispies the part which i hated
the most would be the rings because they
were so hard to get out because they're
so sticky and
and you can't even get them off without
prying and flipping it over after all of
that work after all of that struggle he
didn't like the taffy guys i don't even
know what's happening anymore
[Music]
hello
so if you had to pick one of the alien
meals
as your favorite which one would it be
the winner is
the pancakes
no
oh my gosh
yes
and i present to you
this oh
you're a winner
i won i wasn't expecting to feel so
excited about winning but this really
means a lot because i did try really
really hard on my dish thank you chefs
for creating a dish that would feed an
entire planet of mini moodoos
[Music]
you